pulling down all the data will reduce
latency and maximize the battery
efficiency but it's unlikely the user is
going to read every article so you just
be wasting a lot of bandwidth
downloading all the articles without
pictures actually doesn't improve our
efficiency over just downloading the
front page because you'll still need to
activate the radio to download those
pictures whenever an article is selected
the right answer is to get the headlines
and the articles link to from that front
page is there the most likely to be read
as the user starts browsing through the
app you can then incrementally download
more articles each time the user moves
into an area you haven't prefetched for
yet